da zusammen herzlich willkommen bei zdf
heute live in ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und es ist ja nicht so als ob
intensivmediziner erinnern schon seit
wochen warnen würden dass die dritte
corona welle kein lustiger ritt wird
sondern ziemlich viele menschen mit sich
reißen kann
aber heute hat die deutsche
interdisziplinäre vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin die kinder
das mittlerweile als die wii noch mal
ganz eindrücklich gewarnt und sehr
deutlich gesagt was ich vom derzeitigen
corona groß von bund und ländern hält
nämlich nichts
die leute aus dem sensi stationen waren
die medizinerinnen da würde sich weiter
zuspitzende laufenden einen drohenden
kollaps und das personal das wir schon
lange an der kapazitätsgrenze
daher müssen wir heute mal wieder
darüber reden wie die lage auf der
intensivstation aktuell ist und wie es
sich anfühlt dort zu arbeiten und was
politisch getan werden kann das machen
wir heute mit der intensiv klägerin
nadine robust die ist an der berliner
charité im intensiv team und die kennt
ihr vielleicht aus unserer mini
doku-serie herz und viren
da ist ja auch schon hallo frau robust
hallo
außerdem gibt es dann wenn wir
miteinander geredet haben noch ein
gespräch mit dem intensivmediziner
professor uwe janssens der war bis vor
kurzem präsident der divi und mit dem
innenpolitischen sprecher der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
konstantin coole fragen und kommentare
wie immer ihr kennt das hier unten oder
an der seite oder oben wo auch immer
rein oder per mail sehr gerne an zdf
heute - live at zdf.de das finde ich
dann hier eingereicht
aber wir fangen an in berlin dort sehe
ich die intensiv dickeren den bus bis
vor kurzem noch am pflegebett jetzt
leitungsteam dort auf der
intensivstation
wie war denn der heutige tag in der
charité bei ihnen heute waren ganz
turbulenter tag eigentlich wir hatten
einige online meetings mit anderen
leitungskräften das station sweeting war
heute und was ganz besonders war wir
haben den patienten award verliehen
bekommen also natürlich stellvertretend
für unser ganzes team und zwar durch den
freundeskreis charité
und ja da sind wir ganz besonders stolz
drauf ja und wir freuen uns auch schon
ganz besonders unsere abschiedsparty die
wird nämlich von der prämie dann bezahlt
ja okay dass wir gespannt abschiedsparty
hast was wenn wir hier die türen
schließen wird jetzt schon über eine
große große feier gesprochen
für alle die uns hier unterstützt haben
die hier gearbeitet haben in der
schweren zeit
manche kennen frau ist vielleicht aus
unserer zdf mini doku herz und viren
gibt es in der mediathek kann ich jedem
nur empfehlen alle anderen die sich das
noch nicht angeguckt haben aus
irgendwelchen gründen auch immer wir
haben ja gerade viel zeit zum schauen
stellen wir sie kurz vor mein name ist
niveaulos ich bin 41 jahre alt und seit
16 jahren in den krankenschwestern
seit november bin ich im rahmen der
pandemie im cca eingesetzt das ist eine
spezielle klinik die eingerichtet wurde
für kobe patienten intensiv flüchtige
kuh wie patienten
guten morgen wenn sie mich verstehen
schließen sie mal die augen
wir reden mit jedem patienten egal wie
tief schlafend erscheint die auslagerung
ist ein ganz spezielles manöver also wir
drehen ja den patienten tatsächlich 180
grad um seine eigene achse
das ist nicht so einfach also ich sag
mal bei einem recht normalgewichtigen
patienten brauchen wir dazu vier
pflegekräfte und ein arzt und haben so
schwere der patient umso mehr personal
braucht man dann auch weil man es
einfach da nicht mehr schafft diesen
menschen auf diese kissen zu heben
großes risiko sind immer die ganzen
schläuche die in dem patienten stecken
die ganzen zugänge katheter drainagen da
darf natürlich nichts rausreißen wir
dürfen ihn aber auch nicht drin
einwickeln ist dafür unter dem patienten
nachher nichts liegen
er wurde sofort druckstellen davon
bekommen und ganz großes augenmerk wird
immer auf den wahlumschlag natürlich
gelegt der arzt oder die ärztin stehen
am kopfende und halten den
beatmungsschlauch ist beim drehen weil
es immer ja die größte angst von allen
ist
wenn ich morgens meinen patienten
übernehmen dann setze ich mir meistens
zu tragen zu ziehen und zwar fällt es
mir dadurch leichter die aufgaben über
den tag besser zu priorisieren so dass
ich mein ziel nicht aus den augen
verlieren
[Musik]
ja das war noch aus einer zeit als sie
selber am bett gestanden haben jetzt
seit drei wochen mit im leitungsteam
aber sie können trotzdem glaube ich sehr
gut beschreiben was jetzt gerade bei
ihnen los ist wie sieht die situation
jetzt auf der intensivstation bei ihnen
aus wir passen ständig das
pflegepersonal und damit ja auch die
bettenanzahl an an die steigende zahl
der patienten in berlin wird das ja
recht gut kontrolliert so zu sagen wo
die patientin hingehen werden ein
eigenes konzept und umso mehr druck wir
sozusagen haben für aufnahmen umso mehr
betten müssen geschaffen werden und
damit ist natürlich auch immer
einhergehend die schaffung von mehr
kapazitäten also mehr pflegepersonal gut
aber das fällt ja nicht von den bäumen
das wissen wir mittlerweile wir haben
großen pflegenotstand wo kriegen sie die
her wenn sie sagen okay ich kriege jetzt
mehr patienten
das ist ganz dynamisch geregelt in der
charité und zwar werden einige bereiche
tatsächlich ganz geschlossen um uns zu
unterstützen wir also intensiv
pflegefachkräfte übernehmen mehr
patienten als sie sonst versorgen
dafür bekommen sie aber hilfe von
examinierten pflegekräften aus den
normal stationären bereichen von
medizinstudenten wir haben
servicepersonal aus gastronomischen
bereichen wenn anwalt der in der
intensivmedizin gearbeitet hat von
ärzten die uns am bett helfen ganz viele
berufsgruppen sind bei uns vertreten im
ctk
also der charité campus klinik es sind
tatsächlich schon stationen jetzt bei
ihnen nicht mehr so tätig wie das
eigentlich der fall sein sollte welche
sind das würde sonst nicht klappen
das sind zum beispiel wurde
runtergefahren weiß ich eine
unfallchirurgische station auch so recht
elektiven also geplante op stattfinden
und ich weiß die fachbereiche nicht
genau wir kriegen immer nur die
mitteilen
das wieder normal stationäre bereich
runterfahren geschlossen werden
auch die anästhesie ist natürlich ein
stück weit reduziert immer mehr umso
mehr patienten wir bekommen um so
weiterfährt die anästhesie runter die op
kapazitäten und da kriegen wir auch
personal dann zur unterstützung
wie sieht denn so ein normaler
arbeitstag aus für eine pflegefachkraft
die am somit bett steht das habe ich
letzten samstag auch noch gemacht nur
weil ich im leitungsteam bin bin ich
jetzt nicht gar nicht mehr am besten
auch wichtig ja das wusste ich nicht gut
das ist sagen wir haben was heißt das
denn tatsächlich für sie wir bekommen
eine übergabe zu beginn des dienstes
dann werden wir eingeteilt in die
verschiedenen ebenen
man muss sich das so vorstellen dass
hier mehrere geschosse sind im haus und
verschiedene flure die als ja nochmal
eigene bereiche behandelt werden so zu
sagen wir sind ein großes team
was immer zu dienstbeginn aufgeteilt
wird dann kommt zur übernahme der
patienten die übergabe vom vorherigen
dienst ja und dann schaut man wie man
die patienten jetzt am besten versorgt
bekommt welche hilfskräfte man hat
wieviel anderweitig examinierte
pflegekräfte noch da sind wie man es am
besten auf teilt ich muss nicht mal kurz
an unsere zuschauer innen hier im stream
wenden weil wir sind ja eine sendung die
auch wert darauf legt mit den
zuschauerinnen da draußen zu
kommunizieren aber ich finde es ein
bisschen schwierig wenn wir uns immer
panikmache vorgeworfen wird weil das ist
überhaupt nicht unser anliegen
im gegenteil wir wollen aufklären wir
wollen zeigen wie die situation ist und
dann gebe ich das mal weiter an frau im
bus gibt es einen grund zur panik in
ihren augen eher panik sich immer als
kontraproduktiv
nein besorgnis ja aber panik würde ich
nicht nennen
woran machen sie sich ein konkret sorgen
würde sorgen mache ich mir dass es
irgendwann zur realisierung kommt also
wenn wir wirklich reagieren müssen dann
mache ich mir große sorgen und musste
man die bilderberger mo denken
noch befinden wir uns in einem rahmen
der irgendwie möglich ist aber das ist
halt auch nur ein rahmen und wenn es
über diesen rahmen hinausgeht dann sowas
haben wir alle auch noch nicht erlebt
das weiß ich
nicht was dann kommt das macht mir
sorgen aber würde ich nicht was heißt
denn irgendwie also irgendwie ist ja
schon eigentlich kein zustand
also wenn es irgendwie funktioniert was
geht denn jetzt nicht mehr was früher
möglich war oder was nicht möglich sein
sollte ich diesmal um was immer geht es
für die sicherheit der patienten sorgen
und das ist unser höchstes augenmerk und
alles andere also alles andere fällt
hinten runter das ist auch viel zeit für
patienten natürlich für direkte
betreuung präventive maßnahmen zum teil
müssen jahr reduziert werden
es ist nicht unser normaler job den wir
täglich machen sondern ist es wirklich
also wir sagen manchmal scherzhaft unser
lazarett also wirklich rationierung der
pflege gibt es denn eigentlich schon so
etwas wie alltag ich meine wir machen
das ja schon über ein jahr jetzt gibt's
das schon so ein gefühl okay dass da
habe ich mich daran gewöhnt oder ist es
doch noch jeden tag anders
also ich empfinde es als jeden tag
anders tatsächlich also die patienten
sind anders es gibt zwischenfälle es ist
ja genereller intensivmedizin jetzt auch
nichts besonderes aber es ist besonders
hier durch die vielzahl der patienten
empfinde ich es so dass jeder tag
tatsächlich anders ist ich schaue mal
ganz kurz hier unsere kommentare gibt es
auch die frage nach den pflegekräften
die in den letzten zwölf monaten ihren
job geworfen haben von rolf zum beispiel
der meint 9000 inge kräfte haben ihren
job geworfen die fehlen
unser gesundheitssystem wurde kaputt
gespart wird sich das ändern das werde
ich gleich mal weitergeben an die beiden
herren mit dem wir noch diskutieren
möchten aber wir müssen die situation
bei ihnen also haben sie auch schon
jetzt kolleginnen verloren die gesagt
haben sorry ich bin raus ich kenne
tatsächlich niemanden der jetzt in der
pandemie aufgehört hat also ich liebe
was ich vorhin auch schon gesagt habe
wir haben ganz viele neue kollegen also
auch fachfremde kollegen aber aufgehört
hat bei uns keiner würde ich behaupten
ich weiß von niemanden aber wie ist denn
die stimmung unter ihnen ist es so eine
zum durchhalten ist es tatsächlich so
nah wie sagen lazarett gefühl wird
chinas zusammen durch oder gibt es da
auch schon die anderen
anderen ausfälle auch psychischer art
wir sind geschafft gar keine frage aber
die stimmung war hier immer ganz
besonders in der campus klinik muss man
sagen dass mir sofort aufgefallen auch
als ich im november herkamen und ja
bisher erhalten wir die fahne hoch aus
anderen krankenhäusern ähnlich also ich
habe auch mit mit anderen pflegekräften
bestätigten kontakt sonst du da höre ich
teilweise auch wirklich sehr viel wut
ich stehe ehrlich gesagt gar nicht in
kontakt mit anderen häusern oder anderen
gebiet intensivstationen
das kann ich ihnen gar nicht sagen also
ein mikrokosmos ist hier und in dem
läuft es stimmungsmäßig noch muss man ja
auch sagen gut ich bin zuversichtlich
dass patienten kommen weil die
infektionszahlen steigen ja weiter und
in zwei bis vier wochen werden dann
leute die sich heute angesteckt haben
eventuell bei ihnen auf der station
liegen können sie das noch bewältigen
oder wo sagen sie jetzt ist hier schluss
ja das ist dieser rahmen von dem ich
gesprochen habe
also wenn es über diesen rahmen
hinausgeht also das was wir bisher an
betten und personal organisiert haben
oder unsere valencia die wir
organisieren können wenn es darüber
hinaus geht
da bin ich auch ratlos tatsächlich macht
der job noch spaß gerade ja ich habe ja
wieder eine neue herausforderung jetzt
mit der leitung mit dem management aber
auch der am bett ist nie langweilig
geworden oder ist mir nie zu viel
geworden oder
ja ich habe immer wieder ich habe auch
studiert zwischendurch oder bin kurz
vorm abschluss muss ich ja sagen
der bachelor ist noch auf sich warten
dass es gibt immer wieder neue impulse
und immer wieder anderes arbeiten es
wird nicht langweilig und bleibt immer
spannend dann hoffe ich dass das so
bleibt europas vielen dank für diese
eindrücke aus der berliner charité von
der intensivstation heute und wir
möchten erst einmal noch darum kümmern
was das ganze politisch eigentlich heißt
das ist vielleicht auch für konsequenzen
haben muss es wird er hart diskutiert
über die änderungen
infektionsschutzgesetz über
ausgangssperren und eben
warnungen der die wie heute das
diskutieren wir gleich mit dem
intensivmediziner professor uwe janssens
ehemaliger präsident der divi und mit
dem innenpolitischen sprecher der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
konstantin coole aber wir schauen uns
jetzt erst mal an wie die faktenlage
eigentlich aussieht auf den
intensivstationen kämpfen mediziner
innen und pflegende mit den auswirkungen
der dritten welle wie die situation in
zahlen aussieht dokumentiert die
deutsche interdisziplinäre vereinigung
für intensiv und notfallmedizin
kurzdebüt
demnach sind aktuell 4653 cupid
patienten in intensivmedizinischer
behandlung
die kurve zeigt wie ihre anzahl zuletzt
gestiegen ist nach der zweiten welle
geht es ab dem 13 märz von einem ohnehin
schon hohen niveau wieder steil nach
oben
bundesweit sind derzeit fast 21.000
intensivbetten belegt knapp 3000 wird
noch frei darüber hinaus gibt es laut
die wii noch eine notfallreserve von gut
10.000 betten das sind solche die
innerhalb von einer woche aktiviert
werden können auf die bundesländer
bezogen sieht die lage gerade so aus in
bremen berlin thüringen und sachsen sind
weniger als zehn prozent der
intensivbetten frei am besten sieht es
in rheinland pfalz aus dort stehen noch
gut ein fünftel der intensivbetten zur
verfügung und das diskutieren wir jetzt
mit professor uwe janssens und
konstantin coole von der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
ich fange bei herrn janßen sun die die
wir heute sehr deutlich gewarnt dass der
kollaps droht wenigen jetzt aber
anschauen haben wir gerade gesehen zehn
prozent der betten sind noch frei in
rheinland pfalz sogar 25 prozent und das
könnten innerhalb von einer woche 10.000
betten geschaffen werden da kann man
jetzt auch fragen klingt doch auch erst
mal ganz gut wieso jetzt diese dieser
alarm
also jetzt kann man ja nicht sagen hier
sind ja seit monaten damit beschäftigt
darauf hinzuweisen dass hier eine sehr
sehr sehr prekäre situation entsteht
ich hoffe reden über betten aber ich
glaube
ich muss mal darauf hinweisen wir reden
hier über menschen die schwer erkrankt
sind also ich das kommt dies nicht so
ganz beieinander wir haben frei werden
die benötigen wir um den notfall prozess
überhaupt aufrecht zu erhalten
menschen mit thaksin fakten zur
versorgung mit akuten schweren
infektionen die ja jenseits der coop 19
kranken unser alltägliches prozent
erstens 2 diese menschen die auf diese
intensivstation kommen und dort
behandelt werden die haben ein hohes
sterblichkeitsrisiko das liegt deutlich
über dem was wir bei anderen schweren
erkrankungen leben und ich glaube die
ganze diskussion nur an betten an freien
wetterfest zu machen ist das eine oder
das andere ist an die schicksale von
schwer erkrankten patienten zu denken
die wir doch eigentlich gar nicht sehen
wollen wir wollen doch diese menschen
gar nicht auf der intensivstation haben
und wie können wir es verhindern indem
er tatsächlich infektionszahlen
herunterbringen das sagen wir seit
monaten jetzt gehen die zahl nach oben
und jetzt wird sehr heiß diskutierte
welche maßnahmen denn jetzt geeignet
wären um das endlich wieder in den griff
zu bekommen also ich glaube müssen noch
mal ganz ganz ruhig und zurücklehnen und
sagen was wollen wir wollen dass
menschenleben gerettet werden dass wir
menschen leben beschützen
und das hat mit panikmache oder das was
auch ihre zuschauer gepostet haben
überhaupt nichts zu tun
es ist doch unsere aufgabe und deshalb
müssen wir uns doch nicht angreifen das
dass wir genau dieser aufgabe annehmen
und umsetzen
der coole was will die fdp also erstmal
bin ich dankbar für die schilderung aus
der intensivmedizin auch aus der pflege
es ist so dass die entscheidung die in
dieser und in der kommenden woche im
bundestag getroffen werden und ich hoffe
auch die entscheidungen die in den
ländern getroffen werden in ganz engem
zusammenhang stehen müssen mit diesen
schilderungen erst wird ja auch im
internet viel verbreiteten nachrichten
über die entwicklung der intensiv
kapazitäten über die vergangenen monate
und ich glaube wir sollten hier auf
diejenigen vertrauen die wirklich am
patienten tätig sind und die uns ganz
klar schildern können die situation ist
dramatisch wir haben als freie
demokraten bereits ende des vergangenen
jahres einen stufenplan eingebracht in
den deutschen bundestag der
verlässlichkeit und rechtssicherheit
schafft da ist beispielsweise geregelt
dass bei einer inzidenz von über 200 auf
100000 die schulen in den digitalen
unterricht wechseln müssen insofern ist
es sinnvoll wenn das bundesweite
regelungen gibt was nicht sinnvoll ist
ist wenn diese bundesweiten regelung
neuer fragen auf machen neue
unsicherheiten neue unklarheiten
schaffen und so wäre das eben mit der
ausgangssperre
wie sie jetzt vor der großen koalition
der bundesregierung vorgeschlagen wird
deswegen bundesweite regelung gerne aber
ohne neue unsicherheiten und
unklarheiten über die ausgangssperre
würde ich gleich gern noch mal reden
aber die frage ist ja jetzt doch was
machen wir jetzt die intensivmediziner
haben heute sehr eindrücklich gewarnt
wir müssen das land sofort runterfahren
und auch gesundheitsminister sparen hat
im grunde dafür plädiert wir hören mal
kurz rein was er gesagt hat heute
probiere ich gerade die maz liegt noch
nicht vor da müssen wir gleich mal
umdrehen
die lage auf vielen intensivstationen
wird täglich kritischer die
eindringlichen appelle von
intensivmedizinern sollten wir hören
unser ernst nehmen übrigens auch die
hinweise der pflegekräfte und aller
beschäftigten auf den intensivstationen
dass sie in vielen regionen in vielen
städten in vielen kliniken in
deutschland mittlerweile seit vielen
monaten und der sehr starker
dauerbelastung stehen
deswegen ist mein klarer appell in
dieser aktuellen situation auch an die
länder es ist gut dass wir mit der
notbremse per bundesgesetz bald eine
einheitliche und nachvollziehbare
regelung haben aber wir sollten nicht
darauf warten bis der bundestag nächste
woche dieses gesetz beschlossen hat ich
habe bereits vor einer woche gesagt dass
es zusätzliche massnahmen braucht und
wir konsequent handeln müssen die zeit
drängt bereits jetzt haben alle auch die
möglichkeit schon zu handeln man muss
nicht auf dieses bundesgesetz macht also
wir haben die möglichkeit zu handeln die
fdp auch in nordrhein westfalen wo sie
mit einer neuen landesregierung ist der
coole verweist immer wieder auf die
wirtschaft ist die ihnen wichtiger als
tatsächlich erst zu sagen wir müssen
hier hart bremsen sonst läuft uns das
land und vor allem das gesundheitssystem
gegen die wand
nein es gibt ja viele
wirtschaftsbereiche die bereits seit
über einem jahr ganz massive
einschränkungen hinnehmen müssen ich
will daran erinnern dass anfang november
in der gastronomie im bereich der
freizeit der sporteinrichtungen gesagt
worden ist wenn wir jetzt ein
wellenbrecher locker und so nannte es
herr lauterbach damals machen dann
können wir an weihnachten wieder
aufmachen und siehe da wir sind seit
anfang november nicht aus diesen
strikten maßnahmen herausgekommen
deswegen kann man ganz eindeutig sehen
dass bestimmte wirtschaftsbereiche ihre
opfer gebracht haben wichtig ist jetzt
dass es zu einer massiven kontakt
reduzierung im innenbereich kommt das
ist wichtig und insofern ist auch gut
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister
darauf verweist dass man für diese
maßnahmen überhaupt nicht auf das warten
muss was der bundestag in dieser und in
der nächsten woche berät ich warne davor
dass die länder sich jetzt zurücklehnen
und sich darauf beziehen dass der bund
jetzt entsprechende maßnahmen verweisen
muss die länder haben die möglichkeit im
wege ihrer eigenen corona verordnung
jetzt etwas auf den weg zu bringen es
braucht nur kontakt reduzierung im
innenbereich es braucht weiter einen
ausbau der test kapazitäten auch der im
kapazitäten und hier eine debatte zu
führen bei der es um einzelne
großbetriebe geht das hat mit der
lebensrealität von dem weit
überwiegenden teil der menschen die in
klein und mittelständischen betrieben
beschäftigt sind die teilweise schon
seit monaten auf der waage sagt und
baten um großbetriebe geht es ja gar
nicht vor allem es geht vor allem darum
dass hier wirklich konsequent das land
runterfahren der ganzen stadt gerade
schon gesehen die reaktion sieht man
etwas irritiert ja lieber coole ich muss
ihnen schon mal entgegnen sie haben
einen drei stufen plan genannt dann
nennen sie die schulen instanzen ab 200
die geschlossen werden und dann steigen
sie sofort auszusagen es irgendwie
unverhältnismäßig höre seit wochen auch
von ihrem vorsitzenden lindner das wort
unverhältnismäßig aber so klare
vorstellungen wie sie denn jetzt diese
kontakt beschränkt von den innenbereich
verhindern wollen legen sie ja gar
nichts vor
dann kommt der vorschlag dass man
tatsächlich
in bestimmten stunden aus später sah sie
nein das ist unverhältnismäßig
andere länder wie ich nehme mir jetzt
mal die iren haben das hervorragend
gezeigt sie haben auch ganz klar regeln
aufgestellt die über ein ganzes land
uniform verteilt runter funktioniert das
würden sie den kolleginnen ihren
politischen partei kollegen in irland
vorwerfen sie würden unverhältnismäßig
handeln wenn ich die stadt bezahlen am
gestern heute den tag schaue und da
knapp 600 tote an cupid 19 verstorbene
mit und und daran verstorbene sehr das
halte ich für nicht verhältnismäßig mehr
und ich glaube da müssen wir dringend
darum bitten dass hier eine einigkeit
entsteht und nicht in der
kleinteiligkeit die diskussion hier
wieder auf politischer seite herunter
gebrochen wird sie haben verantwortung
und sie sollten sie übernehmen also sind
300 tote am tag noch verhältnismäßig
sehr coole nein es geht natürlich darum
dass ein stufenplan aus mehr besteht als
einer stufe außengastronomie ist
schneller zuzulassen als innen
gastronomie wechsel unterricht ist
schneller zuzulassen als eine als eine
komplette schließung also hier muss man
sich schon anschauen verhältnismäßigkeit
bedeutet dass unterschiedliche
interessen in einklang gebracht werden
und wir haben heute die polizeiliche
kriminalstatistik uns angeschaut aus der
ganz deutlicher vorgeht wie sich die
zahlen im bereich häusliche gewalt wie
sich die beeinträchtigung gerade von
kindern und frauen in den letzten
monaten entwickelt haben und deswegen
gab es vor einigen monaten mal eine
vereinbarung in deutschland und das war
dass wir im bereich der kinderbetreuung
und im bereich der schulen auf die
verhältnismäßigkeit achten und das bei
der verhältnismäßigkeit auch die
interessen der familien die massive
einschränkungen hinnehmen mussten in den
letzten monaten zu beachten sind aber
trotzdem nicht hierher ja ist es gerade
gestellt hatte die die frage von einem
ganzen ja wie wie wollen sie diese
kontakte im inneren verhindern wenn
nicht zum beispiel einer ausgangssperre
die jetzt auch gesetzlich vorgesehen ist
aber merken sie was sie da gerade sagen
also sollten sie fragen nicht wie sie
alle konnten wie sie kontakt reduzierung
im innern ohne ausgangssperre verhindern
wollen aber das ist doch genau das
gegenteil
wir erzählen den leuten seit über einem
jahr das im außenbereich
es weniger gefährlich ist als im
innenbereich wir haben gerade vereine
wir haben initiativen wir haben ostern
gerade hinter uns wir haben an
weihnachten familien gehabt die haben
alles daran gesetzt das eintreffen
draußen vor der tür stattfinden kann
und jetzt reden wir darüber die kontakt
reduzierung im innenbereich über
ausgangssperren zu erreichen das ist
doch das gegenteil von dem was
erforderlich ist
ich verstehe die diskussion ja es geht
darum über ausgangssperren die
wahrscheinlichkeit zu reduzieren dass
jemand nachts oder abends im
freizeitbereich von einer wohnung zu
einer anderen unterwegs ist und das
macht aber es wird in den nächsten
wochen und monaten auch wärmer werden
ihr müsst dass das wirkliche problem ist
doch dass die menschen müde sind dass es
einen nervenden effekt gibt auf die
leute die das gefühl haben seit einem
jahr immer wieder dieses hin und her bei
den maßnahmen und wir werden die leute
nicht mitnehmen denn wir jetzt mit einer
ausgangssperre das gegenteil von dem
machen was eine kompakte reduzierung im
innenbereich ist da was ist ihrer marke
ausgangssperre ja oder nein
also die ausgangssperre hat den
wissenschaften publikationen gezeigt
dass sie in direkte positive effekte auf
die reduktion des berühmten erwert das
hatte liegt bei 12 bis 13 prozent
man muss doch ihnen nun wirklich alles
politikern und sagen hin und her
sie sind nun nicht die in der regierung
aber trotzdem sind sie bestandteil der
diskussionen die ein hin und her mit
verursacht haben wissen die kleinen
tätigkeiten ich glaube da tragen die
politiker aller couleur eine gewisse und
zwar relevante mitverantwortung
tatsächlich ist es so dagegen vollkommen
recht die kinder und die schulen das ist
wirklich tatsächlich auch von der
politik im letzten jahr überhaupt nicht
den fokus genommen worden man hat so
viel zeit verstreichen lassen aber
wollen wir nicht auf gestern gucken
blicken wir auf freud und auf morgen wir
haben alle chancen der hand das zu
verbessern
in irland sind die schulen glaube ich
auf trotz der vielfalt
da hat man das hinbekommen und ich
glaube die bevölkerung mitzunehmen das
ist tatsächlich aufgabe der politik das
s leadership das ist führen und diese
führung wenn er sich verschlechtert dann
sind die leute auseinander gerissen das
merke ich an meinen patienten auch
keiner weiß mehr wo es hin geht nach
links nicht nach rechts nicht und die
gesellschaft wird durch dieses hin und
her tatsächlich gespalten
ein bisschen zudem tatzeit dass man uns
intensivmediziner vorhält
nur wir würden die wirtschaft zerstören
das ist schon sehr traurig stimmt mich
auch traurig aber ist nicht der fall
wir schaffen durch gesundheit durch
gesunde und der menschen tatsächlich
dass die wirtschaft weiterhin am laufen
bleiben wird das ist doch ganz klar und
auch ja höchst von hat das auch immer
betont
ich denke mal hier werden wirklich immer
wieder äpfel mit birnen verglichen und
ich glaube ich würde mir so sehr
wünschen wenn die politik hier einigkeit
zeigen würde und nicht vor der
gesetzgebung jetzt schon wieder anfängt
um zu diskutieren
das ist wieder schlecht und das ist
schlecht sondern gesagt ja wir machen
das jetzt einmal weil andere haben es
auch geschafft und lassen uns doch mal
zusammen
diesen weg gehen und dann ein
gemeinsames ziel erreichen und dann
werden wir auch einen guten sommer und
einen guten herbst ist dann ist das
überhaupt möglich ja cool ich meine wir
sind eine parlamentarische demokratie
wir sind repräsentativ das heißt
verschiedene interessen müssen
miteinander ringen also ich kann das ja
verstehen herr janssen ist was sie sagen
ich kann auch diese genervtheit
verstehen die aus der die wir über kommt
auch fast die verzweiflung aber auch der
anderen seite her coole ist das
überhaupt möglich in der demokratie
diese diskussionen einfach zu
überspringen
also wir sollten die diskussion ja nicht
überspringen wir sollten sie führen aber
dann irgendwann mal zu einem ergebnis
kommen und ich habe das gefühl dass und
da hat er ganz uns absolut recht ja
eigentlich dieselben diskussionen seit
einem jahr führen und wir hätten im
prinzip schon ende letzten jahres oder
im dritten quartal werden es
wahrscheinlich auch schon früher
hinbekommen wenn das gewollt gewesen
wäre einen stufenplan schreiben können
mit incidents zahlen auf die sich die
länder in der umsetzung dann hätten
stützen müssen und auf die man sich auch
hätte verlassen können als bürgerinnen
und bürger ich finde auch das will ich
ganz deutlich sagen nicht alles schlecht
von dem was die bundesregierung da
vorgelegt hat aber ich habe eben meine
schwierigkeiten damit dass wir
ausgangssperren dort drin stehen haben
andere maßnahmen halte ich für sinnvoll
wie jetzt beispielsweise eine
zahlenmäßige weitere reduzierung der
kontakt beschränkung das finde ich nicht
gut ich finde es problematisch dass der
bundestag bei den rechtsverordnungen
nicht eingebunden ist und ich finde es
problematisch dass das testen und das
impfen auch in diesem bundesgesetz was
uns jetzt vorliegt eine so schlechte
rolle spielt aber der bundestag zeigt
glaube ich dass er so eine
auseinandersetzung
auch in zwei wochen über die bühne
kriegt dass unsere parlamentarische
demokratie in solchen situationen
handlungsfähig ist und länder die dann
etwas zentralistischer organisiert sind
wie frankreich beispielsweise da sind
die zahlen jetzt angesichts der mutation
auch nicht anders deswegen demokratie
und pandemie bekämpfung das geht
zusammen es wäre aber und da hat herr
yannis recht gut gewesen wenn wir das
ende letzten jahres hätten hinbekommen
wollen
und ich will auch sagen herr ganzen dass
sie irgendwie die wirtschaft zerstören
wollen oder so davon von einem solchen
vorwurf der briten sollten sie sich
glaube ich nicht anziehen ich weiß das
sehr zu schätzen dass sie ja auch ihre
erfahrungen und ihre begegnung auf den
intensivstationen mit uns teilen und
auch einen deutlichen appell an die
politiker richten und dass die leute
frustriert sind und dass sie genervt
sind damit müssen wir klarkommen als
politik ja die leute müssen länger
aushalten momentan und deswegen ist es
gut dass wir darüber sprechen ja cool
wir hatten verabredet dass sie nur bis
20 uhr zeit haben das ist jetzt der fall
deswegen muss ich sie leider
verabschieden wir können gerne noch fünf
minuten weiter um 20.10 hätte ich gerade
also sie haben noch ein bisschen zeit
genau
ja okay aber dann wäre doch vielleicht
ein kompromiss um den man ja in so einer
talkrunde vielleicht mal bemüht ist
tatsächlich mal zu sagen für vier wochen
machen wir das land nicht wie vor einem
jahr das ist das was die divi fordert
und es gibt ja auch untersuchungen der
coole die zeigen dass das der wirtschaft
mehr nützt als diesen stadtteil lockdown
den wir die ganze zeit haben
wäre das nicht ein kompromiss aber jetzt
für sie beide soll ich als erstes
anfrage war richtig toll die habe ich in
die runde gestellt wer als erster
antwort hat clip findet zuerst das
gericht hat gewonnen kompromiss ich
glaube und natürlich geht's und
kongresse und ich sage ganz ehrlich eine
sehr coole es ist natürlich so dass wir
in der medizin und auch vor allem die
die mitarbeiter auf den
intensivstationen die karnische ist die
ja einen festen job haben denen auch
wirklich mit herzblut ausfallen wie der
die
leitende krankenschwester von der
charité in mitte zeit hat dass die
natürlich nach draußen blicken und sich
große sorgen machen was in ihrem umfeld
passiert und die haben auch in ihrem
umfeld viele viele menschen die darunter
leiden und das ziel was wir in der
medizin haben ist genau diesen zustand
wieder zu beenden handy zu beenden und
ich bin da ganz ganz ganz zuversichtlich
wir damit unsere kollegen dass uns das
gelingen wird und deshalb und das haben
sie auch gesagt das wird nur gemeinsam
nur gemeinsam gelingen wir müssen den
menschen mitnehmen und ihn in ein
positives terrain führen und deshalb bin
ich so ein bisschen zögerlich über diese
trias zu diskutieren ich glaube wirklich
dass das gesundheitssystem in
deutschland unglaublich gut ist im
vergleich mit dem was immer außerhalb
von deutschland tatsächlich die menschen
zur verfügung haben wir haben so viele
intensivbetten die wir leider gottes
nicht so gut betreiben weil er nicht so
genügend fachpflege kräfte haben aber
trotzdem wir schaffen das aber wir
müssen gemeinsam züge wenn sie dann vier
wochen lockdown ich glaube dass diese
vier wochen helfen würden tatsächlich
die zahlen runter zu bringen und die
impfungen die ja gott sei dank jetzt am
laufen sind in die umsetzung zu bringen
so dass wir tatsächlich im mai juni so
viele durchgesetzt haben dass die zahlen
dann wirklich wirklich nachhaltig
untergehen und auch die schweren fälle
abnehmen hercules vier wochen einfach
einfach mal alles dichtmachen ich
erinnere mich vor einem jahr stand ich
im hamburger hauptbahnhof hab gedacht
was hier passiert aber wirklich niemand
mehr auf der straße das ist heute
überhaupt nicht der fall ist das nichts
was wofür die fdp sich erwärmen könnte
kommt auf die rahmenbedingungen an ich
fand ihr kompromissangebot eben dass wir
uns an dem orientieren was im letzten
jahr passiert ist ganz interessant da
war aber das stichwort immer kontakt
reduzierung und nicht ausgangsverbot es
gab am anfang der panda niemals diese
absurde situation dass in bayern leute
aufgehalten worden sind von der polizei
bedrängt worden sind die alleine ein
buch lesen wollten oder auf einer bank
sitzen wollten ich glaube solche
situationen brauchen wir einfach nicht
wieder wir haben in den letzten monaten
auch einfach gelernt das ist jetzt
gerade im frühling besser ist sich
draußen aufzuhalten als auch noch mit
mehreren drin also wenn wir über kontakt
reduzierung stadt ausgangssperren
sprechen dann kann letztes jahr ein
sozusagen ein modell sein an dem man
sich
orientiert bitte aber dann auch darüber
diskutieren wie die rahmenbedingungen
für die schulen und auch für die
betriebe sind ich weiß dass diese
debatte über die betriebe und über die
wirtschaft mittlerweile auch aus einem
anderen blickwinkel geführt werden muss
weil die mutation gefährlicher ist als
das corona virus noch vor einem jahr das
ist mir alles klar das verstehe ich aber
wir müssen bitte auch verstehen dass die
großen betriebe die rücklagen haben die
eine unterstützung haben auf die sie
zurückgreifen können dass die es
schaffen aber das kleine mittlerweile
dermaßen in die röhre gucken dass sie
auf einen harten vierwöchigen lockdown
nicht vorbereitet sind und deswegen wenn
man sowas vier wochen macht dann muss
das vernünftig begleitet werden mit den
hilfszahlungen dann muss das auch in den
schulen vernünftig mit distanz
unterricht laufen wenn wir das
hinkriegen dann sind auch strengere
maßnahmen als wir sie jetzt haben wenn
die inzidenz zahlen das verlangen
sinnvoll
ok dann machen wir jemanden punkt weil
ich habe einige fragen die gehen immer
jeweils einen herrn jahns oder han yan
coole aus der zuschauerschaft die ich
jetzt auch mal dringend einbinden muss
das habe ich bisher noch nicht getan
weil ehrlich gesagt ist es ein bisschen
schwierig manchmal eine diskussion zu
folgen und parallel noch in den chat zu
gucken
das überfordert dann auch mein hirn
irgendwann ich habe ich hier eine frage
an herrn tode von thomas auf youtube
warum der verweis auf den stufen plan
von 2020
denn wir haben jetzt die variante b 117
das ist eine völlig neue situation und
der plan ist in seinen augen damit
veraltet das tolle an dem stufenplan ist
das eher eine regelungs modell vorsieht
dass in allen ländern gleich ist das
bedeutet dass die länder angesichts der
inzidenz werte die dort enthalten sind
dann handeln müssen das ist genau das
was gerade verlangt wird natürlich kann
man sich darüber unterhalten ob der
stufenplan angesichts der mutation
angepasst wird sie meinen damit
wahrscheinlich niedrigere instanz zahlen
eingefügt werden müssen weil die
mutation geringer ist ehrlich gesagt
dafür bin ich offen das kann ich auch
einfach nicht beurteilen
denn der mediziner sagen das ist so wenn
die rollos virologen sagen das ist so
dann sollten wir das so tun aber das
regelungs modell das wir bundesweit
verlässliche und einheitliche maßnahmen
haben das ist sinnvoll und das
auch sinnvoll dass wir dieser nächste
woche darüber diskutieren aber dann muss
dieses regelungs modell so ausgestaltet
sein dass die leute sich darauf
verlassen können und ich habe auch keine
lust mehr als parlamentarier
irgendwelche maßnahmen aus der zeitung
zu erfahren stichwort beherbergungs
verbot nicht dafür verprügeln zu lassen
und dann wird sowas auch noch eine woche
später von gerichten kassiert weil es
nicht ordentlich durchdacht ist und ich
sehe das gleiche problem bei der
ausgangssperre diesen württemberg baden
württemberg gekippt worden
okay in bayern würde ich jetzt gerne
nicht noch mal an interessant wird das
haben wir gerade dass man blickte schon
einmal durchexerziert dass ein
stufenplan ohne ausgangssperre besser
ist okay
das haben wir jetzt verstanden herr
janssen klaus reichlich schreibt auf
facebook man lässt krankenhäuser
schließen bezahlt pflegepersonal
schlecht und plötzlich verschwinden 6000
intensiv werten aus der statistik und
jetzt begründet man die lok downs unter
anderem damit dass es zu wenig
intensivbetten gibt ist das eine
legitime darstellung der fakten
ja frau wagenknecht ist genauso verkürzt
dargestellt
die auch in einem tweet genau darauf
hingewiesen wir hätten oder man hätte
intensiv werden abgebaut
um das noch mal richtig und
klarzustellen im vergangenen jahr als es
die wir intensiv register was er
weltweit und europaweit einzigartig ist
diese betten einfach mal transparent
dargestellt hat da hatten wir im sommer
ja eine auf erhebung der pflegepersonal
untergrenze die sind dann aber wieder
eingeführt worden
genau in diesem moment kommt es dann zu
einem drastischen absenken der freien
betten
die sind nicht abgebaut die sind deshalb
nicht mehr betreiber weil wir dann kein
pflegepersonal mehr in aus einer menge
zur verfügung haben um die betten zu
betreiben das heißt es kommt zum
automatischen runterfahren der betten
und dann das ist doch tatsächlich so
hatten wir tatsächlich große
schwierigkeiten den meldern den
krankenhäusern im die die register
nochmals zu vermitteln dass sie
tatsächlich ausschließlich die betreibt
barren intensivbetten melden sollten das
sind die betten die tatsächlich dann von
einer pflegekraft in einem
entsprechenden verhältnis betrieben
werden können wir haben mehrere briefe
geschrieben wir sind ja als
fachgesellschaft nicht die polizei die
ordnungsbehörde und haben damit aber
trotzdem nachhaltig erreichen können das
dann dessen
meldeverhalten sich so optimiert dass
halt nicht mehr die freien betten
gemeldet werden so sind dann nach und
nach tatsächlich in einem bereich
willkommen der jetzt absolut reel ist
und wir haben ab januar wieder die
pflegepersonal grenzen verschärft
bekommen auf 1 zu zahlen 12 auch das
verändert noch etwas an der gesamten
situation also in deutschland sind keine
intensivbetten abgebaut worden das ist
eine sache die dauernd durch das netz
geht und die die wird jeden tag
multiples angeschrieben genau mit dieser
frage die sie da gerade gestellt haben
wir betreiben betreibt bahre
intensivbetten und das ist schon eine
sehr reelle zahl und mehr als das mit
einem augenblick angeben haben wir
einfach nicht die klasse haben nicht
aktiv betten abgebaut um damit eine sinn
ein szenario zu schaffen was wir jetzt
gerade die letzte halbe stunde
diskutiert haben dann gibt es eine
meldung von jürgen und bussen dörfer da
geht es mal wieder um die krankenhäuser
die ganz oder teilweise geschlossen
wurden und dass auch sehr massenhaft
also da gibt es ja auch immer wieder
kritik daran was was ist denn daran also
wo liegt das problem
ich bin jetzt endlich deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft ich sage ganz
ehrlich einzig ich bin jetzt nicht auf
experte sogar schließungen
mir ist im gesamten umfeld nrw sind mir
keine akutkliniken bekannt weder in köln
noch im düsseldorfer raum noch in der
ganzen die geschlossen worden wären die
aus dem netz genommen worden wären
wir sind ja bei einer diskussion war
übrigens schon vor der korona pandemie
geführt und die ja im augenblick auch
weiter fortgeführt wird haben wird
tatsächlich zu viele kapazitäten in
deutschland das ist eine ganz andere
frage
wir haben vor der korona pandemie
tatsächlich sehr viel kritik einstecken
müssen und gesagt ihr habt zu viele
intensivbetten gehabt zu viele bekamen
haus betten und hat sich dann
tatsächlich erstaunlicherweise durch die
kampagne gezeigt dass das im vergleich
zum europäischen ausland unser großer
rettungsanker gewesen ist schauen sie
mal werden 34 auf 100000
intensivbetten als 100.000 menschen
intensivbetten frankreich 16 auf 100000
großbritannien szenen die niederlande
6,6 auf 100000 dass diese länder unter
druck geraten sind oder italien szenen
auf 100000 ist doch selbstverständlich
wir werden diese diskussion weiterführen
müssen welche betten wir am fahren
halten aber krankenhausschließungen dass
die jetzt in der argumentativen kette
herangezogen werden würden dass die
ganze diskussion die wir führen absurd
wäre das ist nicht der fall und das ist
mir wirklich kein paradies bekannt was
als akutkrankenhaus vom netz genommen
worden wäre im letzten jahr um damit
eine künstliche diskussion anzufachen
sogar cool ich habe sie gerade abgewürgt
als das im ausgangssperren ging aber das
ist tatsächlich ein thema das viele
menschen bewegt sie müssen jetzt gleich
weg ich hatte ihn zugesagt zehn nach
acht können sie den stream verlassen ich
möchte ihnen aber noch ein paar
wortmeldungen mitgeben es gibt einmal
von einer feier shadow auf youtube die
wortmeldung ausgangssperren bringen
nichts dann gehen die leute um kurz vor
21 uhr zu ihren freunden und um morgens
fünf wieder heim
es hält leute nicht davon ab sich zu
treffen patrick meint es finden die
meisten ansteckungen ja drin statt und
somit aktuell wohl am ehesten privaten
räume und büros wäre eine home office
pflicht daher nicht sinnvoller und von
elke jockenhöfer als letzte wortmeldung
die ich einfach mal mit gebe in die
diskussion
der coole sie wohnen wohl in einem dorf
das glaube ich nicht es sei denn berlin
das center in der stadt sind am
wochenende bis spät in die nacht junge
menschen zu privat partys unterwegs das
würde und eine ausgangssperre
schwieriger werden
das gebe ich hatte nur einfach mit als
feedback bedanke mich sie müssen weg in
den nächsten termin das ist gerade eine
anstrengende zeit für viele politiker da
habe ich verständnis für aber ich danke
ihnen dass sie heute bei mir waren
vielen dank und danke für die
schilderung allianzen und frau hus
können wir vielleicht noch mal schauen
ob es eine frage an sie gibt die jetzt
medizinischer art ist wenn sie noch mal
zwei minuten haben
so etwas haben wir ja tatsächlich auch
immer wieder zum beispiel gab es hier
fragen nach triage ab wann droht eine
triage möchte laura marie wissen woran
ist sie geknüpft und wie wird reagiert
sie ist 24 jährigen risikopatientin und
ich entnehmen wird dieser wortmeldung
als sie sich sorgen macht ja haben sie
viele menschen im letzten jahr sorge
markt wir haben ja im letzten jahr als
es im februar erreicht hatten im märz
erreicht hatten relativ rasch auch einen
positionspapier von levy verfasst genau
zu dieser thematik obwohl wir zu keinem
zeitpunkt weder im letzten jahr noch
jetzt in diese situation gekommen sind
und tatsächlich ärztinnen und ärzten und
behandlungsteams empfehlung an die hand
gegeben wie man vorgehen müsste ihnen
durch einer furchtbaren situation und in
der tat diese situation ist grauenhaft
sich vorzustellen was bedeutet das wir
haben den begriff der träger bewusst
versucht aus dem papier heraus sondern
haben es eher wie gehen wir mit
beschränkten ressourcen um ressourcen
wären an dieser stelle ich nenne mal
ganz einfach beatmungsgeräte wie gesagt
auf zwei infektion führt zu einer
schweren schädigung der lunge und
menschen müssen dann künstlich beatmet
werden dafür brauchen sie
beatmungsgeräte betten
wenn wir jetzt in einem krankenhaus auf
der intensivstation 20 patienten beatmet
haben und unten in der notaufnahme
kommen fünf patienten mit einem schweren
atemversagen steht für diese patienten
kein beatmungsgerät zur verfügung wir
müssen es aber erst die frage stellen
sind in einem anderen krankenhaus betten
kapazitäten frei sind überregional
bettenkapazitäten frei oder sind sogar
in einem anderen bundesland kapazitäten
fall das ist ja das was im moment das
land thüringen macht das ist ja
tatsächlich aufgrund der knappheit
patienten aus ihren krankenhäusern
heraus verlegt und zum beispiel nach
hamburg oder in andere regionen wo noch
eine
gewisse anzahl an kapazitäten vorhanden
ist und diese ganzen maßnahmen müssen
ausgeschöpft werden und es muss vor ort
zunächst einmal ausgeschöpft werden dass
wir aus dem sogenannten routine programm
also herausgehen alle operativen
eingriffe die vertretbar abgesetzt
werden können aussetzen damit schaffen
wir zusätzlich bettenkapazitäten
übrigens auch beatmungs kapazitäten und
übrigens auch kapazitäten im personellen
bereich das heißt die
fachkrankenschwester für alles sie etc
die auch eine spezielle ausbildung hat
kann dann weil sie nicht mehr arbeiten
muss dann auf der intensivstation helfen
die schwester die leitende pflegekraft
von der charité hat das ja eben schon
sehr schön dargestellt so machen das
sind das charité und haben es gemacht
und viele andere krankenhäuser haben
genau diese modelle auch sie zunächst
mal wirklich auch beruhigen kann
ich denke mal wenn diese situationen
kommen die bedeuten würde wir müssen
einen menschen der kaum eine chance
dieses schwere krankheitsbild du
überleben zugunsten eines anderen von
der beatmungsgeräte abnehmen dass dieses
furchtbare szenario tatsächlich zwar
über uns schwebt wie eine dunkle wolke
aber ich glaube nicht eintreten wird
weil wir vorher alles an ergreifen
werden dass wir nicht in so eine
schwierige entscheidung situation kommen
müssen
und das wären dann entscheidungen ganz
tragische entscheidungen die keinem
menschen einfach fall und die wollen wir
nicht und deshalb sind wir doch mit
unserem plädoyers im augenblick dabei
das zu verhindern aber wir wollen in
unserem titel jetzt nicht auf die triage
situation abziehen ich glaube wir müssen
viel früher ansetzen es wirklich gar
nicht in diese bereiche komm lass und
wir haben die mittel an der hand das zu
tun
wir müssen sie nur endlich zwingend
durchgreifend und durchgehend umsetzen
dann kommen wir nicht in die situation
also deshalb müssen wir mit daran
arbeiten das ist um den kritikern direkt
im wind aus den segeln zu nehmen keine
drohgebärde es ist auch keine panikmache
es ist doch der klare aufruf dass auch
wir ärzten ärzte nicht in die situation
kommen wollen
was entscheiden zu müssen dass das
schlimmste glaube ich was man als
verantwortlicher entscheidender arzt
oder ärztin machen müsste es sowas zu
machen und es ist übrigens dann auch
noch vom strafrecht strafe bedroht also
das wollen wir nicht in die situation
werden wenn ich komme und da werden wir
alles daran setzen dass das verhindert
wird damit mache ich das zum schlusswort
herr janssen vielen dank für ihre
ausführungen und für ihre antworten und
ihre zeit heute abend ich sehe in den
kommentaren dass das thema
krankenhausschließungen sehr viele
menschen bewegt vielleicht nehmen wir
dass man mit als anregungen um dann wie
sich schon gesagt haben mit der
krankenhausgesellschaft darüber zu reden
die sind der richtige ansprechpartner
dafür nicht die intensivmediziner die
haben heute sehr deutlich gewarnt dass
wir in die pötte kommen müssen sich erst
mal ganz salopp fehlender ernst für
heute abend und vielen dank auch fürs
zuschauen und für die kommentare und
fragen zum thema wir sind weiterhin für
euch da immer wieder natürlich gerne auf
zdf.de oder in der zdf- heute- app da
gibt es auch einen push mitteilung wenn
ihr uns abonniert und sonst freue ich
mich auf die nächste schrieben und sagt
für heute aber erstmal macht's gut
und tschüss